[Musique]
il faut savoir que c'est un patrimoine
souvent méconnus mais n'aurait alors
qu'effectivement il a employé a
énormément de personnes il ya un effort
à faire en terme de médiation pour que
toute l'histoire industrielle de la
ville sera soit bien connu signifie si
apple canal et y a pas du tout de
développement du sinn un moyen de
transport rentable plébiscité par les
industriels déjà présents dans la région
l'idée est de court-circuiter le
parcours de la loire en coupant à
travers champs
un raccourci de 10 km entre 1828 et 1841
le canal ouvre par petits tronçons une
partie relie montluçon au canal latéral
à la loire au niveau de marseille les
ovnis la deuxième partie traverse le
département du cher le loiret cher pour
atteindre l'indre et loire au niveau de
tours et passe par bourges et vierzon
[Musique]
un endroit voilà et donc là a été cette
partie là les et communales puis la sept
puis vide témoin de cette époque le
portail de la fonderie pose un problème
de conservation pour cette petite
commune de 800 habitants difficile de
rénover les sept hectares du site de
l'usiné métallurgique et d'entretenir en
même temps la commune au savoir que
porteront une petite commune et jeune
commune il était prévu qu'il y ait
quatre mille ouvriers là quand ils ont
conçu le la commune c'était avant tout
pattern la commune et en 1875 c'est
devenu torteron parce que en lien avec
l'uimm est en réalité ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'on a fait des structures
déroulé voit en fait pour accueillir une
petite ville est aujourd'hui nous avons
un petit petite commune un petit village
avec de la voirie et on n'a pas les
moyens
des rues aujourd'hui surdimensionnées au
19e siècle les frères boig imagine une
cité idéale
il faut accueillir les ouvriers dans les
meilleures conditions pour les fidéliser
de l'éducation au mariage en passant par
l'accès à la propriété
tout est prévu pour accompagner les
familles d'ouvriers installé à torteron
c'est un morceau de la halle à charbon
qui a été construite
voyez la date très précise et 1936 avec
deux initiales en entremêlées qu on
pourrait supposer être louis borg
[Musique]
vous voyez cette arche c'est
l'emplacement du haut fourneau 3 ce que
vous ne voyez pas c'est tout les tous
les bâtiments de toutes les halles de
couler pour mouler les tués et les
fosses dans lesquelles il faut imaginer
sous nos pieds des tas de choses qui
sont enfouis ici est écoulé des tuyaux
des colonnes des projectiles
d'artillerie et la fonte destiné aux
rails du chemin de fer alors en cours de
construction tout seul à transiter via
le canal de berry les usines ne vont pas
hésiter à faire un canal privé qui va
aller du coeur de lusine jusqu au chaos
canal de berry ce canal s'appelle le
canal saint louis un peu plus bas à
grossouvre on travaille le fer depuis le
15e siècle avec l'ouverture du canal de
berry en 1837 l' usine sidérurgique
c'est un témoin de cette période faste
la halle à charbon rénové en 2003 elle
abrite désormais l'espace métal qui
retrace le passé industriel du val
d'aubois on a pris conscience que très
tardivement du potentiel du patrimoine
industriel alors que c'est un formidable
atout de développement du territoire
c'est plutôt une fierté tout le monde
n'a pas ça comme cadre de travail
effectivement c'est un beau lieu de
travail c'est un beau bureau
et puis effectivement ben quand on est
amoureux de vieilles pierres
ce patrimoine est effectivement là on
est vraiment servir on est au coeur du
patrimoine et de sa préservation en 1870
l'industrie sidérurgique s'essouffle
dans la région en cause le prix du
charbon et de la houille qui augmente le
transport des marchandises par le canal
de berry n'est plus rentable
les fonderies ferme
le travail de la terre en place le feu
des fonderies en 1901 une tuilerie ouvre
ses portes sur le site de l'usiné
métallurgique
cent ans plus tard l'entreprise imerys
perpétue cette tradition ce site a un
charme qui est vraiment exceptionnel
pour les visiter la mise en avant
veut dire parler de marketing
effectivement mais c'est une image
derrière ce qui est très important c'est
la gestion du personnel la gestion de
machines et aussi la gestion de
bâtiments
on en prend soin parce que parce que on
veut qu'ils durent le plus longtemps
possible et que l'on met le personnel et
du travail l'histoire du site à une part
très importante dans la lutte contre
avec aujourd'hui effectivement et le
marché sur lequel aujourd'hui
imerys a grossouvre le sténopé c'est
justement ces marchés de traditions et
ses marchés historiques tri des tuiles
cuite fait main voilà un reste de cet
héritage autres vestiges imposant datant
du début de la tuilerie un four hoffman
quelque peu défraîchie
celui ci s'est refait une beauté à la
tuilerie sovar de la guerche sur
l'aubois le four hoffmann est le joyau
de la visite un an de travaux 1,9
million d'euros pour réaliser ce centre
d'interprétation d'art et du patrimoine
tout juste inauguré fait ça permettait
de cuir beaucoup de produits avec en
utilisant moins de combustible donc de
charbon
et le charbon était était en fait
alimenté par les puits de chauffe qui
sont donc ces des trous qui sont dans la
voûte du four il était distribué par la
part des cuiseurs qui était au dessus du
four et c'est eux qui faisaient avancer
le feu en alimentant en combustible et
avec des manivelles en assurant tirage
et le lien avec la cheminée qui est de
juste en face de lusine sovar le canal
de berry permettait d'acheminer charbon
et argile matières premières nécessaires
au façonnage des tuiles et des briques
avant 1850 y en avait surtout des
des entreprises artisanales après ils se
sont vraiment développer notamment grâce
au canal et certaines sont devenues
comme sauvegarder tuilerie mécaniques
donc vraiment avec des quantités plus
industrielles la quasi totalité des
usines
enfin des tuileries à mécaniques ont
préféré s'installer au bord du canal
plutôt que la proximité immédiate de
leur carrière par exemple auxquelles
elles étaient reliés par des voies
ferrées une fosse de 27 mètres de
profondeur totalement immergé nous
sommes sur le site de chabrol abef
vous êtes au dessus de la carrière
d'extraction de du calcaire de la pierre
calcaire
c'est la base pour fabriquer de la chaux
pour fabriquer du cidre et c'est une
pierre particulière parce que c'est une
pierre qui va être argileuse puisqu'on
va en avoir besoin pour que ça puisse
faire le lien quand on arrivera au
produit fini pour pouvoir balayer des
pierres entraîne tout simplement pour la
construction et ce calcaire et d'une
qualité idéale c'est pour cela qu'au
début du 20e siècle près de 25 usines à
chiots mécanique s'installe sur le
bassin de bef l'usmh aux deux pôles y
est et chaussons fonctionne jusqu'en
1936 et le canal est encore un point
stratégique
on oublie que il n'ya pas de routes
lignes de ce nom il n'y a pas de chemin
de fer
donc tout se fait par par les canaux
c'est justement à cette époque là où on
va développer les canaux pour pouvoir
amener les matériaux du centre de la
france de l'auvergne et c'est pour aller
vers paris et vers orléans qui
s'industrialise
aujourd'hui il ne reste que très peu de
vestiges de cette époque où l'industrie
faisait le succès du canal de berry abef
le bâtiment le mieux conservé et la
halle à l'extinction de la chaux unal
sauvé par l'innovation
c'est un des premiers plafond en béton
armé de ce siècle sur ce secteur bien
sûr pour les usines et en fait c'est ce
qui a permis de conserver cette halle
parce que si vous l'avez vu précédemment
dans la cour précédentes tous les toits
ont disparu désormais la halle accueille
aussi des expositions d'art contemporain
la conservation du patrimoine industriel
du début du siècle est souvent délicate
mais relève surtout d'une volonté
politique
c'est un site qui était à bander de plus
de 50 ans par les propriétaires donc
politic'show sont et ils étaient ouverts
à tous vents et nous voulions quand même
pour des raisons de sécurité moi en tant
que maire de redemander de vouloir faire
quelque chose pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
problème donc on l'a acquis de paulette
et chaussons pour le franc symbolique
pour l'euro il n'y avait pas l'euro à ce
moment là donc on a fait cette affaire
l'a rénovée en 1993 le site propose
d'accueillir depuis quatre ans les vélos
touristes qui se promènent le long des
canaux
nous sommes sur la l'ancienne usine de
porcelaine rondeleux les usines étaient
placés à l'intersection en général de la
voie ferrée et de un canal on allait
dans le canal de judée rire et la voie
ferrée qui l'a 400m à vierzon les locaux
de cette ancienne usine de porcelaine
ont été réinvestis par une autre
activité
ici la société la bohème produit des
cosmétiques bio fait main et les
vestiges des trois fours sont un
patrimoine que le propriétaire désire
mettre en avant
le schéma du four c'est très simple
c'est un ensemble de trois salles les
unes au dessus des autres
nous nous sommes à la base avec cette
circulation d'air à partir de là l'envié
du feu qui monte dans mur et à partir du
moment où l'air est ramenée vers le sol
elle va venir dans une cheminée centrale
la remontée est repassé sur une salle
plus importantes ou été aussi stocker
les pièces à et en général les pièces
qui étaient décorés était dans ce
deuxième pièce le même type de four est
encore sur pied à main sur yèvre dans
les ateliers de piles 8
il a été construit autour des années
1850 aujourd'hui il est un témoin clé de
cet héritage des porcelainiers du berry
ici c'est une pièce quasiment unique
aujourd'hui en europe même je pense dans
il ne reste quasiment plus à vierzon
ayant je crois qu'il en reste une à
vierzon mais à vierzon et dans les
anciennes porcelaine riz malheureusement
tout a été
tout a été rasé à main sur yèvre les
bâtiments sont encore bien visibles les
hippies 18,7 implanté ici depuis un
siècle
aujourd'hui dans les ateliers les
techniques de production de porcelaine
perpétue une tradition du façonnage des
moules à la décoration
une partie de la production se fait
toujours à la main un savoir faire
indispensable
moi ce que j'aime bien dans mon métier
c'est la matière le toucher le rendu à
la fin quand vous voulez dans dans le
moule que vous avez la pièce et que vous
sortez la pièce j'aime bien le rendu est
ce que ça donne
je pense que ça s'apprend vous savez
tous les jours moi ça fait 36 ans que je
fais ce métier-là mais des fois j'en
apprends tous les jours pour après ce
que j'ai acquis je les acquis entre ses
murs des générations d'ouvriers ont
travaillé la porcelaine
aujourd'hui près de 200 salariés
continuent de mouler ou d'émail et les
objets estampillés piles et vite
c'est une stratégie avant tout c'est de
se dire voilà j'ai un site avec toute
une histoire des valeurs
donc comment via la création via le
commercial via les investissements
industriels aussi qu'il faut adapter en
fonction de la stratégie commerciale
comment on arrive à mouvoir et à vendre
cette histoire et ce savoir les
tuileries les usines à chaud et celle de
porcelaine continuent d'utiliser le
canal jusqu'en 1930
mais après deux guerres mondiales le
trafic sur le canal de berry s'essouffle
les dernières usines met la clé sous la
porte et en 1955 le canal est déclassé
et le patrimoine industriel tombe dans
l'oubli
aujourd'hui tout l'enjeu est de mettre
au jour et de transmettre cette histoire
d'un véri industriels ont